[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
new york real estate developer douglas
durst takes the stand against his own
brother
he'd like to murder me shocking
testimony in the trial of robert durst
as the defendant takes a subtle jab at
the prosecution and
the life of 13 year old dylan redwine
dylan was a
happy going kid the boy's stepfather
describes searching for the teen
as dylan's own father stands trial for
dylan's murder plus
the brave police officers who jumped
into rising flood waters in michigan
to save an 82 year old woman trapped
inside her vehicle
and the so-called widower is back in
court four of his six wives now dead
what thomas randolph has to say as he
awaits a new trial
this is nonsense i want the hell out of
here
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
we begin with testimony from robert
durst's younger brother
douglas durst took the stand and told
jurors he fears his brother
and even higher protection against him
robert durst is on trial for the murder
of his friend susan berman in december
of 2000.
the durst are major players in new york
city real estate douglas durst was
chosen to run the organization
over his older brother the brothers do
not get along and haven't spoken in
decades
on the stand douglas testified robert
left the family business
as part of a 60 million dollar
settlement douglas durst says he took
extra security precautions because he
was afraid of his older brother
why did you hire security what was the
reason for that
because i have fear of my brother has
threatened to kill me and i
fear that he may have the means to do so
despite
everything that has happened how do you
feel about your brother as you sit here
today
first i am frightened and
i also though feel sorry for him for the
situation that we're in i would have
done anything to avoid it
on cross-examination defense attorney
dick de guerin questioned doug
about the allegations surrounding his
involvement with the disappearance of
katie dearth
gave every appearance of wanting to find
her at the time didn't he
yes there have been allegations through
the years
that accuse you or the durst
organization or seymour
or even mr lewing lewin of
colluding to cover up
kathy's disappearance right that
allegation has been made
i can speak for my family but not mr
lewin
you're insulted by it aren't you
and you know that seymour would not have
done anything to cover up bob's
complicity if he believed that bob was
complicit
that is correct yes
on redirect prosecutor john lewin
questioned doug about his
brothers how his brother felt when his
wife went missing
and your words were that he seemed
distraught when he told you that
catherine was missing do you recall that
testimony i do
yes do you know if he was actually
distraught
he did he did not seem as distraught as
i would have been if my wife was missing
for three days
and to whatever level he appeared
distraught do you know if that was
genuine
uh there's no almost no emotion that bob
shows that is genuine
on a break attorneys again brought up
the need to empty the bag
connected to duress catheter prosecutor
lewin offered to keep helping durst
change it
durst responds in a voice that can be
hard to hear
saying tell him no it will inhibit me
from making him look like a fool
when he cross-examines me the issue of a
consultation etc whatever
consultations mr nurse is going to have
is one thing
but obviously this is very simple the
bag just needs to be emptied
i'm more than happy to do it thank you
thank you
i'll take it from here thank you thank
you
[Music]
joining us today is correspondent
engineer levy and terry austin
and jeanette sparks were flying and have
been flying between the defense and
prosecution from the very beginning
now durst is jumping in what did you
make about durst
uh's remarks to prosecutor lewin well i
think it was classic robert durst
you know he's been sitting there quietly
he's spoken out against his attorneys in
the past right before this trial
began he thought that they were
suffering from dementia or something
like that he wasn't pleased with them so
he doesn't
hold back he doesn't pull any punches
and he thinks he's met his match here
and i think he
seems to think he's going to make mince
meat out of john lewin he has a story to
tell and he wants to tell it
i mean i can't wait to see that thank
goodness law and crimes got cameras in
there because it's going to be exciting
when he takes the stand
terry even his younger brother was
afraid of him does this
fact put durst right where lewin wants
him as someone capable of murder
absolutely no question about it i have
never seen a case
where the brothers the siblings of the
individual of the defendant is afraid of
him
they know for a fact that kathy durst
has disappeared
they know for a fact that maurice black
is gone
and durst admitted to chopping him up
and they also know that susan berman was
shot dead
and he himself the defendant has
threatened both of the brothers so
it's understandable that they are afraid
of him
and it does put durst right where the
prosecution wants him he's definitely
capable of murder
absolutely if your own brother is afraid
of you what would
others say as well i think john lewin is
doing a great job of painting the
picture as to
who robert durst is for the defense and
to maybe bring up reasonable doubt i'm
not sure
just yet but the jerry's going to have a
lot to digest here thank you both
still ahead on law and crime daily the
capital gazette shooter back in court
after his guilty plea but first the
trial of a father after his 13 year old
son was found murdered in colorado
more heartbreaking testimony about the
death of dylan redwine
next
[Music]
welcome back dylan redwine's stepfather
takes the stand
along with the fire chief who helped
search for the missing boy
law and crimes angela levy is back with
what both of them told the judge the
jury
anjanette yeah brian dylan redwine's
stepfather talked about what he and
dylan's mother did to try to aid in the
searches for
dylan and he also told the jury about
who he saw near the road
where dylan's remains were eventually
found
michael hall testified that dylan only
visited his father a couple of times
after the fire at mark redwine's home
in 2010. did no one ever come back from
mark redwine's house on those
trips with any bleeding injury of any
kind
no hall also testified dylan would often
not respond to his father's texts
mark would try to get a hold of dylan
with no success
then mark would then start texting
elaine hall recalled how he and dylan's
mother
helped with the searches for dylan
months after dylan went missing hall
said he saw mark redwine
in an area that would later become
significant i saw mark redwine
coming down middle mountain road
in a white dodge dakota truck two months
later
part of dylan's remains were found on
middle mountain road
mark redwine's attorney suggested
investigators didn't try to involve his
client
in the search do you know if law
enforcement also
contacted mr redwine to identify item
i do not laid back nonchalant
was there any emotion no sir
retired deputy fire chief roy vreeland
describing mark redwine's demeanor
as he searched for dylan breland used a
dog to track dylan's scent but came up
with nothing
he was set up outside of mark redwine's
home did you ever see him come out of
the house at all to check in
i did not
now roy freeland suggested that mark
redwine or
mark redwine suggested to roy vreeland
rather that
dylan may have gone fishing at a lake
that was about nine miles away
so they started focusing the search
efforts on that area
and when asked vreeland said that mark
redwine told him that dylan would have
likely walked
to that lake brian interesting angela
let's bring back co-host terry austin
terry michael hall's testimony is really
starting to fill in the blanks
uh for the prosecution was there one
thing about that testimony that made you
think
oh red wine's guilty well there were
several things brian that stood out to
me first of all there's no question
that the stepfather has a much closer
relationship both to dylan and
corey compared to their father and so i
think that
shows that there was a problem as far as
the defendant's personality was
concerned
and it also stood out to me that
the stepfather michael was very involved
in all of the searches and what really
impressed me brian is the fact that he
hired a team with sonar to search
that lake and to me that means you're
going above and beyond and that you
really care about
finding dylan and it shows just the
opposite in contrast as far as the
defendant was concerned he didn't
get himself involved in most of the
searches but the thing that
really stood out brian was the fact that
michael hall saw mark redwine's
truck in the area where eventually
dylan's remains were
found and so there's something about
that what was he doing he ran away
when he actually saw michael hall's
car as well so i think that's very
suspicious yeah very powerful point for
the prosecution and jeanette
how is the defense trying to explain
mark redwine not participating
in searches for dylan you know they've
suggested that you know the whole
community was turning on mark redwine
that even elaine hall had been to a
rally in front of
mark redwine's home that everybody was
looking at him as public enemy number
one
so of course why would he come out and
join these people when they're all
you know suspecting him of being
involved in dylan's disappearance
but you know he was the responsible
parent at the time
he dylan was in his care in his custody
so you would expect him to maybe be a
little bit concerned if his son
disappears
on his watch and it doesn't sound like
to a lot of people that he was
absolutely now terry do you think that
michael hall's testimony
is going to be the nail on the coffin
for this case or is there still some
reasonable doubt left for the defense to
work with
i think there is still some reasonable
doubt but michael hall's testimony
absolutely helped the prosecution i
think that the jury is looking at him
and the jury likes him and believes him
and so it's going to help at the end of
the day as far as building
the entire case absolutely thank you
both
coming up on law and crime daily iman
bundy faces a jury in idaho
a week after announcing his run for
governor
plus police officers jumping into action
the harrowing rescue of an elderly woman
trapped in her vehicle
as flood waters continue to rise the
video you don't want to miss
next
[Music]
welcome back the capital gazette shooter
is back in court
as a jury will now decide if he was
legally sane at the time
of the mass shooting jared ramos pled
guilty to 23 charges stemming from the
june 28
2018 shooting that left five people dead
inside the newspaper's building
defense attorneys say ramos was insane
for years before the attack
and remain so to this day since the
burner approved for the phase lies in
the defense
they are calling witnesses to present
evidence first prosecutors are reserving
their opening statements for after
defense's case
investigators believe ramos was out for
revenge and spent years planning the
attack
carried out three years ago
and in idaho the trial is underway for
the controversial anti-government
activist
ammon bundy bundy was arrested twice at
the idaho state capitol in august 2020
after leading a group of massless
protesters against the state's
stay-at-home order
he's facing a charge of criminal
trespass for actively disturbing
legislative hearings
and refusing to leave the state house
earlier this month
bundy announced his bid for governor of
idaho in 2016 bundy led an armed
standoff against federal agents in
oregon
he was later acquitted the man accused
of killing a tennessee deputy could face
the possibility of the death penalty
if convicted a judge has ruled steve
wiggins is charged with the 2018 murder
of sergeant daniel baker
investigators say wiggins shot baker six
times before setting his patrol car on
fire
wiggins is also accused of using baker's
radio to talk to other deputies
pretending to be baker attorneys for
wiggins accused the state of showing a
bias towards baker's family and
colleagues
wig is set to stand trial next month at
the time of his death
baker was a lead investigator on the
baby joe daniels case
the missing five-year-old's father was
convicted earlier this month
and in michigan police officers rescued
an 82 year old woman trapped in her
vehicle
as rising flood waters swept it away
dash cam video shows two officers in
clinton township
entering into the murky water the
woman's vehicle was almost fully
submerged
and still sinking as the water continued
to rise a third officer rushes in
and swims towards the vehicle after just
seconds the officers emerged with the
woman
carrying her to safety she was conscious
and alert but taken to a hospital for
observation
the woman later told local media she had
been driving in what she believed to be
a simple puddle
when her car was picked up and swept
away she said she was swallowing water
when the police got there
it was like i had arms of god around me
the woman said describing the officers
who saved her life
all right let's bring in co-host terry
austin and correspondent angenette levy
to get the reactions to the rescue first
terry what do you think about this
brian i thought this was an amazing
rescue not only were these police
officers in the right place at the right
time
but they thought quickly they took
everything off jumped right in the water
and thank goodness they did what they
needed to do they are true heroes
and your response to this as we said a
harrowing response to these
by these officers yeah i'm just glad
that they were able to get to her
that is one of the most terrifying
things i think that somebody could
endure is drowning like that and we've
seen
stories about this in the past you know
reenactments of people
trying to get out of vehicles and it's
very difficult so i'm just glad that she
was rescued
and that they got there just in time and
of course like the local authorities say
be careful of driving over
uh water even six inches of water can be
deceiving and sweep your car away
and of course there are plenty of safety
measures that you can take as to how to
get out of a vehicle in an emergency
thank you both angenette and terry when
we come back
four of his six wives are dead but could
thomas randolph be off the hook for all
of their cases
here from the so-called black widower
next
[Music]
welcome back the so-called nevada
widower has strong words for the judge
presiding over his case
he was granted a new trial but now says
he can't properly prepare with his
attorneys
thomas randolph was convicted and
sentenced to death for hiring her hitman
to murder one of his six wives
in las vegas prosecutors say randolph
then shot the hitman and called 9-1-1 to
stage the incident
ranof has been dubbed the black widower
four of his six wives are dead
his conviction and sentence was tossed
out last year because at trial
prosecutors mentioned the 1986 death of
randolph's wife
he was tried and acquitted in that case
now randolph is getting ready to stand
trial again next year
but he says he can't meet with his
attorneys in prison to review evidence
and is telling judge
she better do something about it
this is nonsense i want the hell out of
here
and i know when these lawyers see what
there is to see
they're going to file the appropriate
motions and they're going to ruin your
day
and they're going to run the state's day
because then you are going to grant
these these motions that they file and
i'm going home
it's that simple but it's not going to
happen
until they come and see me till they
have access to me
i've been waiting 14 years
i've had 25 attorneys it's getting old
so you have to step up and make these
people do what they need to do
well the judge didn't exactly appreciate
randolph telling her how to run her
court
you can't dictate when the lawyers are
going to come visit you okay
these lawyers are going to come visit
you when they can arrange to come out
and visit you i am not going to sit here
and guarantee you that that's going to
happen on july 10th
because then if it doesn't happen mr
randolph when i'm talking you're not
i'm not going to guarantee you that
we're also not having a status check
date on
july 16th i'm going to set a status
check date momentarily but i'm about to
hear from mr orr
because he would like to be heard go
ahead mr arm your honor just so the
record is clear i'm confirming today
i know mr randolph has serious issues
and i'm going to work with mr randolph
and mr ornos
i'm confirming today i'm just i know
very limited
uh information about the case but we're
going to make sure that mr randolph is
visited
his issues are taken care of the
appropriate motions are filed
and so i want to assure the court and mr
randolph of that
and randolph had one more thing to tell
the judge that he's filed his own motion
and that he wants her and his attorneys
to read
i filed a motion i don't think you've
got it yet is that correct
that is correct okay basically
what this motion is and it's i'm filing
you're not going to tell me what the
motion is
when i get the motion i'm sorry you're
not going to tell me what the motion is
today because the motion is not on
calendar and i'm not going to decide it
because i haven't read it
when the motion gets filed i'm going to
read it and then i will decide it at
that time
okay that's what i had asked if we could
do that on the 30th so i guess you'll
decide that
let us know now this is an interesting
development that is so unique to the
pandemic usually
uh when the pandemic was not going on
your client was standing next to you and
making these demands you can kind of
turn to the side like
don't worry about it but this brings in
a whole new colorful background
and jeanette i'm sure you've seen
clients speak to judges like this
before how do you think this is going to
play out for randolph after this
appearance
you know i don't know i thought the
judge showed a lot of restraint because
i've seen a lot of judges who would not
have put up with that for one second
um so thomas randolph obviously thinks
that
he is going to be acquitted and uh he
thinks he's running this show
and he is not running the show and the
judge let him know that so
it'll be interesting to see how he acts
in the future during other court
appearances
yeah absolutely i think in his mind it's
the thomas randolph show we're all just
extras in it but to that point terry
but for the prosecutor mentioning a
previous case randolph
may have been convicted so what do you
think randolph wants to show
that proves his innocence or do you
think it's a whole lot of nothing
it is a whole lot of nothing here he is
absolutely bluffing
the evidence is really stacked against
him brian i mean yes
his trial was overturned he did get a
break there as far as that's concerned
but there was so much evidence against
him not the least of which was the fact
that there were 218 phone calls with
miller miller is the one he hired
to kill his wife sharon so there's no
question that he
killed his wife he killed the person he
hired to kill her so there would be
no evidence and you know i think that's
going to come out again
regardless of what they talk about in
terms of the other
four out of six wives that are no longer
uh with us
hey it's still going to be interesting i
can't wait to see how this plays out
he's at least confident
that something's going to prove his
innocence we'll see how that plays out
when the trial begins
and jeanette terry thank you for joining
us and thank you for joining us here on
law and crying daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you